مشاهده مرحبا بكم في قناه الجزيره نقلت
وكاله رويترز عن مسؤولين رفيع في الاداره
الامريكيه انا مسؤولين امريكيين كبار
نصحوا اوكرانيه بتاجيل شنه هجوم كبيره على
القوات الروسيه الى حين حصولها على
امدادات اضافيه من الاسلحه الامريكيه
والتدريب على استخدامها
ايمن الخلاف على اعمال اجتماع حلفاء
اوكرانيا في قاعده اينشتاين بالمانيا بشان
امداد اوكرانيا بالدبابات وقال رئيس هيئه
الاركان المشتركه الامريكيه الجنرال مارك
ميري انه سيكون من الصعب نحو القوات
الروسيه خلال السنه الحاليه من كل جزء
احتلته في اوكرانيا واضاف ان الحرب في
اوكرانيا يجب ان تنتهي على طويله
المفاوضات على غرار العديد من الحروب في
العالم
عادله وزاره الدفاع الروسيه السيطره على
بلده كلها شيفكه الواقعه جربيه باخموت في
منطقه الشرقيه اوكرانيا وكانت ميليشيا
الروسيه اعلنت اول امس سيطرتها على البلده
التي تقع على بعد تسعه كيلو مترات
هذا المتحدث باسمي مجلس الامن القومي
الامريكي انه وزاره الخزانه الامريكيه
الروسيه
عابره للحدود
اضافيه عليها اضافه كير بانها الرئيس
الروسي باتي يعتمد عليها بشكل متزايد
تلقت محكمه العدل الدوليه طلب الرسميه من
الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده بشان ابداء
الراي والتبعات القانونيه لاحتلال
الاسرائيلي الاراضيه الفلسطينيه وفي
بيانها اوضحت المحكمه المسائل التي طلبت
فيها الامم المتحده الراي وهي التبعات
القانونيه الناشئه عن الانتهاك المستمر من
قبل اسرائيل لحقوق الشعب الفلسطيني
ياتي بيان المحكمه بعد ما اعتمدت الجمعيه
العامه في قرار اواخر ديسمبر طلب فتوى
محكمه العدل الدوليه في لها
وعباره الخارجيه الفلسطينيه عن ارتياحها
لتسلمي محكمه العدل الدوليه طلب الرسميه
من الجمعيه العامه للامم المتحده بشان
ابداء الراي بخصوص احتلال اسرائيل اراضيه
الفلسطينيه
واكدت اكد احمد الديك المستشار السياسي
لوزير الخارجيه للجزيره ان السلطه
الفلسطينيه ومؤسساتها جاهزونا للتعاون مع
المحكمه بكل الطرق
رغم تهديد رئيس الوزراء الاسرائيليين
نتنياهو بالرد على اي تحركات فلسطينيه على
الساحه الدوليه
الموجز شكرا لكم اينما كنتم فعلا
[موسيقى]